on en a fait des tonnes sur le recyclage
de nos déchets notamment sur le
recyclage des plastiques en martinique
est manifestement ça semble un peu plus
compliqué que prévu bonjour ici redresse
bonjour vous êtes le directeur de cidre
et placide red sea la société
industrielle de recyclage et de
production qui a vu le jour il ya quatre
ans avec comme objectif de récolter les
plastiques notamment les bouteilles pour
les recycler les remettre dans le
circuit afin de réduire la quantité de
nouveaux plastiques que nous faisons
rentrer dans notre île 4 après ça semble
pas fonctionner dites nous pourquoi tri
sur torres alors le but de cidre eh ben
je reprend les termes qu'on est
d'employer le but de cidre est pas été
de grâce à la collecte sélective qui est
organisée par les opci locale ce que
l'on traite l'eau sous lé voilà sous la
gouvernance de l'ex eco emballages qui
est devenu si théo c'était de récupérer
ces plastiques de lait transformés en
granulés qui devaient être destinés en
grande partie à les alimenter la matière
première de la société mpm est aussi une
société du groupe qui fabrique des
bouteilles pour le marché local depuis
19 ans voilà donc c'est pour cette
raison que nous avons créé cidre ep
et malheureusement le système
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas la société
cidre ep n'arrive pas à avoir les
tonnages nécessaire à faire fonctionner
son système car depuis 19 ans la société
matières plastiques martiniquaise
fabrique la plupart des bouteilles que
nous qu'ils ont offerte par trois
chiffres
trois chiffres combien de matériaux qui
viennent d'où quelle production promet
d'argent ça nécessite alors écoutez en
ce qui concerne mpm nous importons
environ 2000 entre 2500 et 2700 tonnes
de matières premières par an qui
viennent de lituanie ou du mexique
oui pour quelle production ou la vie
dans nos produisons environ entre 85 et
100 millions de bouteilles par an pour
destiné pour la martinique pour lamah
pour la martinique pour les
embouteilleurs de martinique
d'ailleurs les trois les trois
principaux leviers sharif lors didier
chasles flore et la snbg qui est le
distributeur coca cola aux antilles
alors si drep dans son plan de bataille
devait permettre de faire quoi au bout
de 4 combien de bouteilles auraient dû
être aurait récupéré pour une
fabrication produisait le cercle ont
fait parler les chiffres cc c'est
beaucoup plus simple jeu voilà
aujourd'hui nous aurions besoin de deux
au minimum 2000 tonnes qui rentrent sur
le site de cidre est pour pouvoir faire
face à tout ce que l'on a à payer c'est
à dire aussi bien aux salariés leur
charge des fournisseurs locaux que nos
banquiers et aujourd'hui on n'y arrive
pas alors pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas
à qui la faute c'est le tri sélectif
c'est le ramassage le manque
d'information auprès de la population
qui en demandent pourtant à chaque
instant que le bon dieu fait sur terre
de recycler de 10 3 ide de faire le tri
sélectif
écoutez je pense que vous faites et les
questions et les réponses puisque à
messi mais que ce soit vous série
d'experts renommés tout à fait mais je
réponds vous inquiétez pas je pense
qu'on accuse eu beaucoup le martiniquais
ne pas avoir le geste nécessaire si vous
voulez pour que l'opération fonctionne
voilà donc ça c'est un premier comme ça
est ce que c'est vrai je crois pas tout
à fait est-ce que l'organisation qui est
mise en place si vous voulez sous le
contrôle de la cité haut pour que cette
collecte soit effective
on va préciser tout de suite que la cité
aussi cet organisme au niveau national
qui est censé gérer la collecte de
déchets exactement alors j'explique en
deux mots ce que ces sites est aussi
vous laisser le nouveau nom de la
société eco emballages qui perçoit une
taxe sur chaque bouteille où chaque pot
de yaourt qui sont produits en france
donc à la martinique
et cet argent si vous voulez il leur
distribuer aux collectivités aux pays
qui sont chargés si vous voulez de la
collecte sélective et de la mise sur le
marché des produits triés par le trio
local espace sud cap nord est et est
cassé ma pour une fois la 7e n'est pas
krummi ni avait en fait alors ses trois
communautés d'agglomération font-elles
le job
et pourquoi ne le font-ils pas alors
écoutez moi je pense que la meilleure
réponse qu'on puisse y avoir c'est de
poser la question à ces gens là tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que dans le
nouveau contrat qui est proposé
aujourd'hui sur le pci par citéo il n'y
a pas d'accord qu'ils aient trouvé ça ça
dure depuis six mois alors peut-être que
les gens les petites que les
responsables ont une bonne raison
c'est vrai pour ne pas signer ce contrat
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
directement impliqué auprès des ces gens
là pour pouvoir apporter des réponses
que seuls eux peuvent vous apporter
en même temps c'est un acteur de la
filière oui absolument absolument parce
que si vous voulez on parle bien des des
communautés d'agglo qui organise les
rotations des engins qui viennent
récupérer les plastiques déposée par les
martiniquais dans des bandes de
ramassage et de tri voilà est dans les
bacs ce qu'on appelle les bacs jaunes
tout à fait alors le savons pas l'heure
ce soyons clairs sur un problème koné
d'évoquer voulait évoquer la collecte
les jeux des douanes personne en disant
que les gens qui ramassent c'est à dire
les compagnies de transport et de
ramassage qui sont organisées sur la
martinique si vous voulez ne travaille
que sur ordre des epc
donc c'est pas de leur faute mais c'est
à dire c'est pas leur faute s'ils
passent une fois tous les quinze jours
alors que peut-être il faut dépasser
toutes les semaines ça c'était justement
ça fait partie des choses qui peut être
peuvent irriter les martiniquais qui
sont on va le rappeler
taxer chaque fois davantage lorsqu'il
achète une bouteille d'eau le
constructeur de du produit contenu dans
la bouteille d'eau est taxé pour le
recyclage tout le monde est taxé mais ça
ne fonctionne pas
c'est un petit peu ça c'est même tout à
fait ça bon alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
de son internat parce qu'il ya de
l'argent il ya de l'argent pour cette
récolte cité où l'avez vous l'avez si tu
es responsable france de cette collecte
injecte de l'argent pour ça en
martinique comme et d'argent mais
écoutez d'après les chiffres donnés dans
le journal france antilles par les
responsables de citéo il y aurait en ce
qui concerne le plastique 1 parce que je
je veux pas parler de choses je connais
pas en ce qui concerne le plastique
citéo injecterait 600000 euros par an en
martinique pour que se place ils
assoient collecter trier 600000 euros
pour quelle teneur bah écoutez les
chiffres très précis que je vous donne
une sorte de lusine cidre est puisque
nous tenons une comptabilité très
précises puisque chaque kilo après on
aura beau mais chaque kilo que l'on
rentre chez nous le payons nous a cité
il ya une petite erreur sur le journal
france antilles a cité au ne donne pas
d'argent c'est nous qui payons citéo
pour la matière première et on a rentré
en 2017
nous avons rentré sur le parc 500 tonnes
qui venait du centre de tri locale donc
si vous voulez du tri de martini
interdit lorsque city au injecte près de
2 millions pour la martinique ça fait
combien la tonne ça alors écouter ils
n'ont pas injecté 2 millions ils disent
si théo donne des chiffres en dix ans
nous avons mis six cent mille euros sur
le marché pour la collecte des
plastiques
donc si vous voulez je vais faire un
bémol c'est qu'il ya une petite quantité
de plastique de couleur qui ne rentrent
pas chez cidre est parce qu ils ne sont
pas très table chez nous parce qu'on n'a
pas de marché pour ça donc mais chez
nous nous avons rentré 500 tonnes donc
si vous voulez si on fait un calcul brut
s'ils ont dit 600 mille euros santos a
fait 1200 euros la tonne alors hollande
mais temps si on les quais de la couleur
au milieu on arrive quand même à milon
on arriverait quand même à 1000 euros la
tonne pour la collecte et le tri oui on
peut quand même se poser la question à
quoi sert cet argent
bien égoutter normalement cet argent il
sert à organiser justement la colle est
la collecte mec mettre des bacs de tri
en nombre suffisant ce qui est quand
même nous savons quand même encore là
aussi très en dessous de ce qui se fait
en france c'est à dire le nombre de bacs
par rapport au nombre d'habitants
ce sont des statistiques officielles que
je n'invente pas je peux les chiffres à
vous donner mais on peut donner
information là dessus voilà si vous
voulez normalement ça devrait
fonctionner comme ça alors maintenant il
faut interroger si vous voulez les
responsables de ces deux pays pour
savoir quel est le problème qui zonent
de manière à arriver au résultat où on
est aujourd'hui
vous entendu on espère bien qu'ils vont
ils vont répondre à la question lorsque
nous allons leur leur poser si drep
était censé pouvoir fonctionner bien
regarder ce qui se passe en guadeloupe
regardez ce qui se passe en guyane vous
nous disiez avant d'entrer dans ce
studio que nous avons quand même une
petite expérience sur le papier de la
collecte de déchets beaucoup plus grande
que ce qui se passe en guadeloupe et en
guyane mais non va-t-il tout de suite la
sonnette d'alarmé ce sont deux îles de
pays de régions qui nous va très très
vite raconté
en ce qui concerne la guadeloupe le tri
sélectif a été mis en place bien
longtemps après celui de la martinique
cependant aujourd'hui s'ils voulaient
nous avons reçu 380 3 tonnes de
guadeloupe et en martinique c'est sans
la martinique c'est ça alors que nous
avons des années des années d'avancé sur
le sujet quand elle a quant à la guyane
séoul et je pense qu'ils vont nous
rattraper d'ici d'ici deux ou trois ans
pour la bonne raison que dans 10 cl
d'eau 3 officiellement il y aura
beaucoup plus d'habitants qu'à la
martinique et qui en perd qu'un tous les
jours et donc si vous voulez le système
qu'ils ont mis en place un nouveau
système qui apparemment fonctionne pas
trop mal dans les endroits où
l'exploitation a été installé et je
pense qu'ils vont se développer arriver
un jour à produire plus par contre si
vous le jour et pour eux durant beaucoup
plus que nous produisons nous les
produits de guyane pourront probablement
nous échappent et parce que le coût du
fret entre la guyane et la martinique
est tellement élevé que ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher d'envoyer ses
produits en europe ont signé aujourd'hui
d'une autre preuve que ça patine en
martinique et me voilà avec ces chiffres
on patine
alors concernant on va rappeler que si
drep travaille essentiellement sur
bouteille tous bouteille un bottle to
bottle vous dit exactement que vous
récoltez des bouteilles en plastique
pour les sociétés style showfloor didier
somes etc etc
mais il n'ya pas que ces bouteilles il y
en a d'autres qui arrivent en martinique
les autres marques evian cristalline qui
rentrent en martinique ça c'est quel
pourcentage de bouteilles écoutez le je
vous donne les chiffres simples et les
les chiffres donnés par citéo qui
connaît pour l'un son boulot 10 il ya
douze mille tonnes par an
voilà on en ramasse en a ramassé hilton
pour la martinique
oui on a ramassé ça et vous ouais et
2500 tonnes de bouteilles
donc si vous voulez il ya bien un
endroit où où les bouteilles se
retrouver bon je retrouve en hausse et
où un mais voilà dans cyrano de porc
comprendre c'est que si on ne comprend
pas c'est qu'on ne veut pas comprendre
c'est simple c'est à peu près ça ouais
et il ya quand même un impact sur
l'économie parce que le recyclage de ces
simples bouteilles de plastique pour
être rayée énormément d'emplois
morphiniques août et nous nous avons
monté une usine qui est capable de
traiter 4500 tonnes par an ce qui ne
représenteraient finalement qu'un tiers
de ce qu'ils aient reçu tous les ans
soit émis par un pme soient reçus par
bateau ça fait pas beaucoup
si on fait tourner cette usine disons
autour de 3800 4000 tonnes
nous créons qu'un 22 emplois aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nous avons du
mal à 1 p en payer à faire travailler
cet ordre on ne parle que de simples
bouteilles de plastique par exemple
lorsque je vais au supermarché que
j'achète tac il ya ce plastique et kiki
henri boutet il y a par exemple je
regarde l'interrupteur du courant
électrique de ce studio c'est du
plastique l'ordinateur qui devant moi
c'est du plastique tous ces plastiques
là pour être recyclés et générer des
emplois martinique absolument alors s'il
voulait après vous avez une question de
taille et par exemple vous faites
allusion à ce qu'on appelle les
plastiques placentaire et plastiques
d'emballage et des packs de bouteilles
millions pour on pourrait imaginer si
vous voulez à condition que ce ne soit
pas toujours les mêmes de développer une
filière dans ce sens là merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nos prix sont investis
retour est directeur général de la cie
dre persie bonne journée merci à vous